[Music]
vatican city is an inspirational place
you don't need to be catholic or even
religious to appreciate the architecture
the art and the city's historical
significance but there is a place within
the vatican that's rarely seen hidden
beneath the city is an underground
fortress inaccessible to the public and
protected by armed guards and
state-of-the-art security the secret
apostolic archives within the stone and
steel reinforced walls are vaults
climate-controlled rooms and over 50
miles of shelves and on those shelves
are countless texts relics and artifacts
collected by the church for over a
thousand years and one of the most
intriguing objects hidden in the archive
is called the chronovisor a device that
can view events anywhere and anytime in
history and for years its existence was
just a rumor no proof of the chronovisor
was ever found but a book released by a
vatican priest would change all that
let's find out why
pellegrino ernetti was a scientist
world-class authority on music and a
scholar he spoke several languages he
dabbled in electronics physics and even
the occult arts he also happened to be a
benedictine monk now whether by luck or
by fate father pellegrino or neddy found
himself in the company of francois brune
a priest from france and they were
sharing a ferry ride down the grand
canal in venice the water was calm and
the trip was long so the men struck up a
conversation they shared a love of
languages science and history and they
were discussing different
interpretations of the bible when
hernetti interrupted there's nothing to
interpret ernetti said it's possible to
see what actually happened to see the
truth with your own eyes the broom
thought ernetti was joking or being
rhetorical
he wasn't ernetti spoke of a device he
had worked on hidden in the deepest most
secret levels of the vatican archive a
device that allowed its operator to
witness events anywhere and any time in
the past and it was called the
chronovisor do a time machine sort of
you can't travel anywhere with the
chronovisor but you can program it to
show you certain events on a screen like
a television oh boy you can stream
anything these days now francois brune
was stunned by the story he knew father
pellegrino ernetti to be a serious man
ernetti was well read well educated and
well respected in the church he was not
one for exaggeration yet ernetti claimed
to have heard speeches by napoleon and
mussolini he visited ancient rome and
ernetti was amazed that cicero was as
captivating as speaker as history
claimed my name is maximus desmos
viridius commander of the armies of the
north general of the felix legions and
loyal servant to the true emperor marcus
aurelius father to a murdered son
husband to a murdered wife and i will
have my vengeance in this life what a
next
are you not entertained
i'm not anyway broon wanted to know
about the events in the bible did they
really happen it's all true ernetti said
he had seen the final days of jesus
including his crucifixion he saw the
creation of the ten commandments the
last supper the destruction of sodom and
gomorrah and everything in the bible the
broon was obviously skeptical even
though ernetti was intelligent and
talented he didn't have the skill and
knowledge needed to build this kind of
device and ernetti agreed that he
couldn't build the chronovisor himself
he had help
[Music]
in 1952 father pellegrino arnetti was
working on a project at the catholic
university of milan and being an expert
in early christian music he was studying
and restoring tape recordings of
gregorian chants while listening to one
of the tapes the school's founder father
agostino jameli was convinced he heard
his father's voice even though his
father was dead at the time of the
recording but what gemelli heard was not
his dead father relaying some profound
message to his son from beyond the grave
what he heard was more mundane his
father arguing with someone over the
price of shoe wax jamelli's father was a
cobbler who made and sold shoes and
jamelli thought he'd been given a gift
from god but hernetti wondered if there
was a scientific reason for this that
the sights and sounds of people in the
past somehow continued to exist long
after they happened and if they did
could they be detected
well it does and this technology is not
that different from what we now call
evps or electronic voice phenomena and
since jameli was president of the
pontifical academy of sciences he was
able to fund a project to explore the
possibility of listening or seeing
events from the past ernetti assembled a
team of 12 scientists but he would only
reveal the names of two and one was
enrico fermi the nobel prize-winning
physicist known for fermi's paradox and
for creating the world's first nuclear
reactor the other scientist was nazi
rocket scientist turned director of nasa
werner von braun like sound waves can be
pressed into vinyl to produce a
recording ernetti said that his team had
discovered that light and sound
continued to exist as forms of energy
and using a series of antennas the
chronovisor could detect this residual
electromagnetic radiation and translate
it into image and sound operators of the
chronovisor could designate a specific
date and location then the scene was
reconstructed on a large cathode ray
tube now francois broome was obviously
amazed by the story and asked her nettie
what happened to the device bernetti
said that once the team realized what
they had invented they brought their
discovery to the pope and since the
chronovisor can tune into any place and
time in the past it could be used as a
powerful weapon it could reveal state
secrets or be used for blackmail so pope
pius xii worried that in the wrong hands
the chronovisor could launch a
dictatorship unlike anything the world
had ever seen the pope ordered the
machine dismantled and forbid anyone
from speaking of it ernetti said this
was the first he's spoken of it in over
10 years and brune understood and agreed
that a machine like the chronovisor
would be extremely dangerous and it was
probably best if it stayed hidden and
dismantled but brune said tornetti it's
too bad there's no proof that the
chronovisor actually worked ernetti said
to brune my friend i have proof
quintus inius was a writer and poet who
lived during the roman republic between
239 and 169 bc he's often considered the
father of roman poetry and during his
lifetime he wrote about 20 plays and an
epic poem on the history of rome called
the annals but only a few fragments of
his work survive his final play the
estes was produced shortly before his
death in 169 bc and scholars have
wondered about this play for centuries
they knew the story was based on the
writing of another author seneca but the
actual text of theestes except for a few
lines has been lost to history ernetti
used the chronovisor to visit rome in
169 bc where he saw a performance of the
play in a roman square ernetti fluent in
latin was able to transcribe and finally
complete enes's play after 2 000 years
and that manuscript still exists the
story of the chronovisor remained hidden
for another 12 years or so then in 1972
an article appeared in the italian
magazine le domenica del corriere
the headline of the article was a
machine that photographs the past has
finally been invented and some believe
that the chronovisor was not dismantled
but was actually functional and being
used by the church to maintain watch and
control of the population that theory
makes sense oh you you believe that one
huh
in the woods
soon several photos were leaked
including this one taken by ernetti
himself ernetti used the chronovisor to
view jesus's entire final day including
his crucifixion my favorite photo is
this one which shows jesus walking and
talking with his followers
and this photo is also pretty compelling
but again the chronovisor fell out of
the public eye all the information was
suppressed by the church or that well
then in 2002 francois bruin released his
book called the new mystery of the
vatican which documents his relationship
with ernetti and includes more details
of what ernetti saw with the chronovisor
and even includes blueprints for the
machine
and father pellegrino ernetti passed
away in 1994 but until his dying day he
swore the chronovisor was real he even
published an open letter saying so
father francois brune passed away in
2019 and during his life he published
multiple books and papers on theology
and its relationship to quantum physics
he gave talks on evp phenomena
communicating with spirits and many
different aspects of parapsychology he
too until his last day believed the
chronovisor existed and possibly still
exists today two highly regarded and
well-respected clergymen insisted that
the vatican is in possession of the most
important most advanced and most
dangerous scientific invention ever
created the vatican denies this claim as
fantasy so
who's telling the truth
[Music]
the chronovisor is a story that bothers
me
on one hand there are a lot of details
that are easily debunked but on the
other hand the story comes from credible
sources father pellegrino arnetti was
well known and highly respected by his
peers he spent most of his life
researching teaching and writing and his
books are highly regarded father
francois brune is also well known and
respected so why would these men of such
high esteem risk their reputations on a
lie of this magnitude what was there to
gain their entire lives both men said
this device existed and possibly still
exists but the legend of the chronovisor
does have a few problems first anyone
who can confirm that it existed in the
first place is dead when the story first
emerged fermi had been gone a long time
and von braun while still alive never
mentioned it von braun had a lot of
secrets though he sure did and it's fair
to point out that both fermi and von
braun worked on multiple top secret
projects during and after the war now
the photos associated with the
chronovisor are fake the crucifixion
photo is actually a picture of a statue
from a church in central italy and the
sculptor was lorenzo valera a relatively
famous spanish artist who created the
statue shortly before his death in 1931.
when confronted about this bruin said
valera took inspiration from a nun who
had seen a vision of the crucifixion and
that's why the statue is so similar to
the photo taken from the chronovisor but
to me they don't look similar they look
identical but father brune said the
photo was real and there are other
photos associated with the chronovisor
but these became attached to the story
over the years they don't come from
ernetti this one is sometimes attributed
to the chronovisor but it shows up in
other urban legends as well it's a
photograph but not one taken through a
time machine it's a photo of a painting
by german artist johannes rafael vela
it's called jesus among the wheat fields
and was painted around the year 1900 and
this photo is another that's become
attached to the chronovisor this is a
photograph of a painting by eugene
bernande called peter and john running
to the tomb dated 1898. so what of
ernetti's transcription of the estes
well it doesn't hold up ernetti had
written about 150 lines which he said
was the complete play but experts are
pretty sure the play would have been
much longer than that probably a
thousand lines or more and linguists
aren't impressed with the transcription
scholars have said the latin is clumsy
and uses words that wouldn't appear in
the language for at least 200 years so
whoever wrote it wasn't a native speaker
in 1994 just after ernetti's death a
letter was published by someone who
claimed to be a distant relative of his
but wanted to remain anonymous this
person said that on ernetti's deathbed
he confessed that the photo and his
writing of the estes were fake and that
enrico fermi had nothing to do with the
machine but he still claimed the
chronovisor was real then another
distant relative said ernetti made the
whole story up to get more people
interested in the church i don't trust
when distant relatives suddenly crawl
out of the woodwork well father francois
bruin didn't trust them either he
insisted that the chronovisor was real
and if fernetti confessed it was because
he was coerced to do so by the church
i believe well that brings up an
interesting side note now obviously the
catholic church said the chronovisor
wasn't real but in 1988 the church
issued a strange decree but said if
anyone was caught using a machine like
the chronovisor they would immediately
be excommunicated so if the chronovisor
is fake why bother releasing a statement
like that at all when i first heard the
story of the chronovisor it was one that
i desperately wanted to be true and many
people believe it is true believers say
the church keeps the chronovisor a
secret but does use it occasionally to
influence world events and that's
something to think about if the
technology exists that allows someone to
view anyone anywhere and at any time in
history we wouldn't want any government
to have such immense power and the only
worst institution to be the steward of
this technology that i can think of is
an organized religion
so with that in mind
i don't know if the chronovisor is real
but for all our sakes i really hope it
isn't
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share those
things really help a small channel now i
love the secrets of the bible and the
vatican so i'd like to do more of these
and if you want to hear those stories
let me know in the comments until next
time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you